all right hi everyone
uh welcome to cs330
and uh today we'll be talking about
hurricane Colorado and skill Discovery
um these are quite exciting topics
some of them are a little bit out there
so please ask questions if if something
is unclear but first a few reminders
so the homework for the optional one is
due on Monday and then on Wednesday we
have the project Milestone that is due
as well
and then one more announcement next week
we'll have two guest lectures and this
should be really exciting so we'll have
Colin raffle here uh who will talk about
big language models this will be virtual
lecture so you'll attend on zoom and it
will start at noon as opposed to uh 11
30.
um so he'll probably talk a little bit
about how meta learning just emerges
when you train on big enough data sets
especially with language so it could be
really interesting
and then on Wednesday we'll have uh
Joshua Sol dextein who will talk about
learning optimizers which is kind of
another way of approaching metal
learning and he's done a lot of work on
the topic so it would be I think it will
be very interesting to to see to hear
what he what he has to say and this one
will happen in person
at the standard time
all right
so let's do a little recall so we've
been talking about reinforcement
learning for a little bit
for actually quite some time right right
now and we have these different kinds of
reinforcement learning that we discussed
there is the online reinforcement
learning or on policy reinforcement
learning
then we have off policy reinforcement
learning Where We Gather some
experiences we put them in the buffer
and then we have certain set of
algorithms that can deal with with data
like this
and then in the last lecture on Monday
we discussed offline reinforcement
learning where we don't get to interact
in the world we can just access the data
that was already collected uh for us and
then we have to learn the best possible
policy given that data set
we also talked about a few different
tasks throughout the lectures on
reinforcement learning for instance we
talked about grasping in the single test
case when we discuss QT opt
we talked about different simple
manipulation skills when we talked about
empty UPS such as pushing grasping
specific objects placing rearranging and
so on
and then we also talked about uh goal
condition reinforcement learning where a
task is specified by a goal and this is
where where we talk about actionable
models where we would present a a goal
image that we want the robot to achieve
and then the robot will try to get to
that as close surgical image as possible
so so far we we knew what we wanted
right we had some kind of task in mind
it was specified in different ways
sometimes there's a one-hod vector
sometimes as a language instruction
sometimes it's a goal image but we but
we knew what the task is
we also if you if you look at all of
these tasks here then rather short
Horizon behaviors right so maybe they
span tens of time steps maybe hundreds
of time steps but they're relatively
short simple manipulation skills
and then lastly we had well-defined
tasks and well-defined rewards so this
is kind of equivalent to knowing what we
wanted we we knew that we want to
optimize for certain for certain tasks
and then we could just go ahead and
optimize for them and then we would test
on those tasks
so today we'll talk about something a
little bit different
something where we want to maybe
discover interesting behaviors we want
to have agents that can discover
interesting behaviors on their own
right so we want to specify the task
we'll try to avoid specifying tasks and
instead we would just want to have an
agent that we can just deploy in an
environment and have it find out
everything that there is to find out
about that environment and come up with
its own tasks
so one reason to do this is uh
there's it's also part of how we learn
right so here's a little time lapse of a
of a baby left unattended and it does
all kinds of different things without
being explicitly told to do so right and
these seem like some targeted
exploration Behavior so just it's
curious about the world and its
explorers and tries a whole bunch of
different things and it comes up with
its own tasks we don't have to sit down
and specify what is the task that we
want the baby to do
in addition to this there's been some
research in biology some research on on
frogs
showing that there's actually a small
number of core skills that the spinal
cord of the Frog uses to control all of
the movements of the Frog so there's
just a handful of skills then then the
spinal cord can modulate to create a
whole variety of behaviors that we
experience when we watched frogs right
so but there's just a handful of them
and they span this whole this whole
variety that we get to observe
there's also a similar research done on
human subject or that that Drew a
similar conclusion where they invited
human subjects and they asked them to
grasp different objects and then they
record it using I think motion capture
system they recorded all kinds of
different grasps how they were
performing the the tasks
and then they collected that data set
and then they run principal component
analysis on it and they found out that
most of the behaviors can be understood
or can be
described by just using a few top
principal components
so it seems like it's a similar
conclusion where maybe there's just a
few core skills that we need to learn
and once we know about those skills and
they're well parameterized then we can
use those skills to emerge all the kind
of behaviors that we might want in the
in the world
now you know we could try to think of
what these skills should be right we
could try to prescribe them and kind of
through trial and error find out if
these are the right ones or not
but much more natural way would be to
have the agents leave them unattended
and have them explore the entire world
and try all kinds of different things
that they might be interested in and
then we can take that and then find the
core skills that spanned at space
all right there's also a more practical
motivation for skill Discovery
algorithms
so we talked a little bit about this
during actionable models
that actually coming up with tasks
themselves can be quite tricky
all right so um actually let's run this
little exercise so let's think of a
tabletop manipulation scenario so we
have a single arm robot that is in front
of a table it has limited workspace it's
just a single arm it has a parallel jog
Ripper so it just has two fingers that
can just grasp like that
and can you just shout what are the
different tasks that you can come up
with what can this robot do
any ideas just show up whatever comes to
make yep
stack okay
pick in place yep push and pull okay
sorry what is it
yep slide kind of similar to push and
pull maybe a little different
rotate things okay
drop them so you'll drop them from the
table but then you would need to pick
them up from the from the floor again uh
yeah assuming that you can reach there
yep that's a good one yep but when you
do this
okay
manipulation of the formable object so
like pull a rope or put a rope in a
certain configuration or something like
that or use a cloth or something like
that
any other ideas
fold something yeah also using maybe the
formable objects cool awesome yeah these
are some really good ideas so all
together maybe we came up with 20 tasks
or so
um and what if we want to have robots
that can do you know kind of anything
that you can imagine right like
thousands of thousands of tasks
but if they're presented with different
objects and with that and with some
scenarios that we haven't thought of
before
and um actually coming up with all the
different possible tasks and we want to
come up with as many tasks as possible
because the more tasks we have the
better generalizations we'll have to new
tasks this is quite tricky
so we we run through this exercise when
designing this Benchmark called meta
world and we're able to come up with 50
different tasks and some of them are
very similar to the ones that you
mentioned but there's also additional
considerations that you should think
about when thinking of a benchmark like
this so for instance tasks need to be at
similar level of difficulties so that
there's no one test that is way way
harder than some of the other tasks they
should also be able they should also be
accomplishable within a similar time
Horizon so that you don't have this
imbalance during training as well they
also need to be every single task needs
to be solvable using standard single
task reinforcement learning algorithm
and sometimes it's it's quite tricky to
to get that to work so there's a lot of
different constraints we're able to come
up with with 50 of them but it was
actually quite painful to do that
so one one reason why we would want to
do skill Discovery instead is what if we
could just drop a robot in that
environment and spawn a bunch of
different objects maybe randomize them
from time to time and have the robot
figure out on its own all the kinds of
different things that it can do in this
environment and then we can just name
them afterwards
all right so we might need some kind of
skill Discovery to discover these
behaviors and today we'll also talk
about hierarchical reinforcement
learning so why hierarchies and why
hierarchical around
so we are pretty good at performing
tests at various levels of abstractions
we as humans so for instance I can give
you an instruction to bake a cheesecake
and you wouldn't necessarily think about
you know how to contract your muscles to
bake a cheesecake you can think about on
a much higher level of abstraction so if
you were to plan the first step you can
say well first I need to buy the
ingredients and then you can go lever
level and then you can say well first
step for this is I need to go to the
store
first step for this is I need to walk to
the door
I need to take a step to do that and I
need to contract a certain muscle to
take that step
and we can plan on all these different
levels and if we were to plan some long
Horizon tasks like Becca cheesecake on
the lowest level of abstraction it will
be an extremely long plan that we
wouldn't be able to even think about
so we want to do something similar for
our artificial agents we want them to be
able to reason about different levels of
abstractions on the different time
Horizons so that they can plan for
longer things
and then in addition to this it seems
that these hierarchies and different
levels of abstractions are really
helpful with exploration
so here is a video of a of a baby trying
to accomplish a task and it's not really
clear what the task is but it's just
trying different things and then at this
point it's it's stacked this block and
then it looks for approval whether this
was the right task
so in this case it's doing exploration
on this very high level of like well I
probably need to pick some objects I
probably need to place them somewhere
you know these are kind of high
abstraction skills it's not really doing
exploration on the motor babbling level
where it's just like moving its hands in
all kinds of different directions and
looking for approval
so if we could have something similar if
we could have this much more targeted
exploration that explores through higher
level Concepts will be probably will
probably have better exploration
algorithms
all right cool so the plan for today
as we'll talk first about information
theoretic Concepts and we've talked
about a lot of them already so this
might be mostly a review for most of you
but we'll just make sure that everyone
is on the same page there
then we'll talk about skill Discovery
algorithms
and then we'll talk about how we can use
the skills that we just discovered
and then at the very end we'll also talk
about hierarchical reinforcement
learning
cool so let's start with information
theoretic Concepts
so we'll start with an entropy
but before we talk about entropy we have
to talk about the distribution and
hopefully at this point most of you are
familiar or all of you are familiar with
what the distribution is
so we can plot it here on the x-axis
this one-dimensional random variable X
and the y-axis is the probability
and we can look at what kind of values
this random variable takes
plot them on this x-axis and then try to
fit a distribution to it for instance a
gaussian that shows the probability
density of that
so now let's think about what an entropy
is it's an entropy of a distribution
and it's written with this script h
a symbol
and the formula if you were to look it
up
looks like this
all right so let's think a little bit
about what it what it actually is so we
have a minus sign and then we have a log
probability log P of x
under the expect of the expectation
under its own
right under its own distribution
so what what does that mean so
let's think a little bit let's let's
think about how can we make entropy very
very small
all right so how can we take this whole
term and make it very small
so for this term to be small then this
term without the minus needs to be big
so what does that mean
that means that we would need to sample
right
yes we want the end the full entropy to
be small so then this whole thing is to
be small so then this thing needs to be
big
actually let's switch that let's make
the entropy back okay so let's try to
see what what would it take to make this
turn back so this whole thing needs to
be big so then this part needs to be
small
so for this part to be small we would
sample something from our distribution
so our sample from our distribution
and then the lock probability of that
sample needs to be small
all right
so what that means is that I just
sampled something but the probability of
me sampling that thing is actually quite
low so I just had it by chance sample
something that was I wasn't actually
that likely to sample
so what that means is that basically all
of the samples that I'm going to sample
are not going to be very likely
in other words the entropy controls how
broad our distribution is if our
distribution was uniform random right
like if the probability of sampling any
potential value was the same
then if I sample that particular value
the log probability of that value will
be very small
right so the more random the
distribution is
the
um the the higher the entropy
so in this case it will tell us how wide
this gaussian right here is
how broad it is
yep
peace
so yeah so the question was for the
uniform distribution within the lock
probability be very large so if it's a
uniform distribution other let's imagine
a gaussian that is really really broad
right then the lock then the probability
the lock probability for each sample
would be relatively small right we will
spread this this peaky gaussian across
the x-axis so it will be kind of small
here smaller here smaller here small
here
no locks locks this thing lock doesn't
change the
its monatomic function
so then you have a small probability
so log doesn't change the
um the value of the
um
if if so basically the the corresponding
the big values will stay big they'll it
will just squish them the smaller values
will stay small
okay
so let's think of another example of a
bernally random variable so let's think
of a case where we are just flipping a
coin
and we can set the probability that the
Bernoulli the the parameter of the
Bernoulli distribution so the
probability with which we'll be we'll be
getting heads or tails
and that that parameter is set here on
the x-axis so if it's 0.5 that means we
have an unbiased coin and it's as likely
to get Tail as it is to get heads
now if we were to plot the entropy of
that of that distribution dependent on
the parameter it would look something
like that
so it basically says that the entropy
will be the highest
when the the coin is very unbiased right
so when it's kind of the uniform
probability where we don't really know
what's going to happen
right the the sample is basically uh the
sample will carry a lot of information
in other ways so the other way you can
look at it is that if the entropy if the
parameter is really high for instance
one or zero and if you were to do an
experiment if you were to take a coin
that always shows heads then the entropy
of the distribution will be very very
small what that means is that this
experiment is not going to reveal much
more new information to you you already
know what's going to happen right if you
have a coin that always shows you heads
then you don't really have to toss that
coin you just you know that it's going
to be heads there is not much
information in that experiment but if
you have a unbiased coin then you know
throwing then tossing a coin will
actually give you a lot of information
so it's there's a lot of value in
performing that experiment and that
corresponds to high entropy
all right
let's talk about another concept which
is kale Divergence
so kale Divergence we we talked about
about it a little bit during especially
our offline rail lecture
and we talked about it as a distance
between two different distributions
so let's define a little bit more
strictly let's define it mathematically
so the definition of the KL Divergence
between two distributions q and P
as defined as this as defined as the
expectation under the first distribution
Q of the log of the ratio of the two
distributions
right and you can see that this is not
symmetric the order matters and we'll
talk about that in a second
so we can write it out because the log
of the ratio is the difference of the
logs so we can write it out like this
and then given that we already know what
what an entropy is we can take this term
because this is the log probability
under its own expectation and it's just
missing a minus sign so we can say that
this is a negative entropy so I just
switched it here and this is the
negative entropy term and this term is
the same term that we have right here
all right so this is a distance metric
so let's first see what happens if both
of these distributions are exactly the
same right so when Q equals p
so
um if Q equals P or P equals Q then we
would have the this term would would
just have q Q's in here this term would
have just Q's in there and there will be
the two exact same terms we'll subtract
one from the other the distance will be
zero
versions between two distributions that
are exactly the same as zero so that
seems to make sense that seems like a
decent distance metric
but let's think a little bit more about
what it actually means
all right so let's do the following
experiment we will have some
distribution that is given to us that is
a little bit funky this is the
distribution P of X and I plotted it
right here right so this is what it
looks like
and now we'll try to find another
distribution Q
which is a gaussian so we are restricted
to this gaussian family
that minimizes the KL Divergence between
q and P
right so we're trying to find the
distribution q that is a gaussian that
will minimize the Cal Divergence to this
distribution
so first let's take a look at this term
right here
so this says we we're trying to minimize
the whole thing
so we're trying to maximize this term
right
and this term says that under the
expectation of Q so I'll be sampling
from Q the log probability of P of X
should be high
right
so that's that's how we can minimize
that
so that means that we can find some kind
of gaussian so that if we sample from
that gaussian the lock probability of P
of X of this funky distribution will be
as high as possible
so one gaussian that that fits that
description is a very peaky gaussian
right here
that covers the same mode as P of x
right does that make sense so because if
we sample anything from that gaussian
the log P of x
log P of X so the probability of of this
distribution of these samples here will
be very very high
right so this is the first term
and now we have the second term
which is the the entropy term so we are
minimizing the whole thing so that means
we are maximizing the entropy and to
maximize the entropy of that caption we
already know what we need to do we need
to make it broader
right so in other words to minimize to
find the Q distribution that is a
gaussian find the parameters of that
gaussian that minimizes the KL
Divergence between q and P which is this
funky distribution we'll end up with a
gaussian that covers the mode of this
distribution
right
so I have one question to you which is
what will happen if we change the order
right what would happen if
um we were optimizing KL differences
between p and Q and not q and P
foreign
that optimizes only this term and tries
to maximize this little term right here
why is it so peaky and wouldn't we have
the best scale Divergence if we just
match the distribution exactly yeah so
these are kind of two separate questions
so let's first answer the second one so
why can't we just find the distribution
that's exactly the same that's because
we are restricting ourselves to just a
gaussian family
so the only thing we can we assume that
we can fit is a gaussian right so this
is kind of the best gaussian we can find
that minimizes the Cal Divergence now
regarding the second question why is it
so uh so narrow and it's so peaky here
is because if you put any probability
Mass anywhere else right like if we make
it a little bit broader and this term
would be a little bit smaller right then
if you sample from that gaussian the
lock probability of that will be a
little bit lower you'll be a little bit
lower on that on that x-axis here
so the best thing you can do is find
kind of the most narrow gaussian that
finds the mode of the distribution and
then if you sample from that gaussian
the lock probability your your y value
here would be very high
foreign
if somehow we were not restricted to the
caption that we could model any
distribution somehow what would we
minimize the calendar versions with the
exact same distribution yes so the Cal
Divergence would be zero if it's the
exact same distribution yes
[Music]
how deep is this like kind of maximize
yeah so all of the terms that I will be
discussing today so entropy KL
Divergence Mutual information
information gain are closely related
and there's close relationships between
all of them we'll talk about some of
them in a second so that will hopefully
resolve some of that
right cool so
we had this other question which is what
would happen if we change that order
right so right now we have this mode
seeking behavior and that's actually how
people refer to it so we'll try to find
a gaussian distribution that covers the
mode of the P of X so what would happen
if we change the order yes
foreign
that's right yeah so the Q of X is not
allowed to be zero if P of X is zero so
basically it will try to cover the
entire support of P of x
so it will be a gaussian that goes like
this
that's right and we refer to the scale
Divergence as a uh
sorry this one was mode seeking and this
one is mode covering so it tries to
cover all the modes
all right cool
so one more term and that's Mutual
information we haven't talked much about
it so let's do it now
so mutual information is denoted with
the script I and it's mutual information
between two random variables
and it's defined as following as the KL
Divergence between the joint
distribution of these two variables and
the product of the of their marginals
right so let's think a little bit about
what this means so this is how we can uh
plug in our KL diversions formula to
this but first let's maybe do a little
example so mutual information measures
the dependence between two variables and
this is a symmetric measure so if I told
you something about X and that would
reveal a lot of information about y that
means that they're dependent and they're
there's High Mutual information between
them and if I could tell you something
about X and it doesn't really help you
with knowing anything about y that means
that the mutual information is low
so in these two cases we have a plot of
X and y's so if I did tell you the the
value of x if you knew what the X event
was you could relatively you could know
actually quite a bit about y right you
would have it would reveal quite a bit
of information about what y could be
versus in this case even though I could
tell you what x is
it doesn't really tell you that much
about what y would be these are
independent variables
so in the first case we have high Mutual
informations X and Y are dependent on
each other
and in the second case we'll have low
Mutual information X and Y are
independent of each other
all right
so we can actually rewrite Mutual
information as an entropy so you can do
this by doing a little bit of algebra on
this formula right here
and uh it actually results in something
like this so it's an entropy of one
variable
minus the conditional entropy or the
entropy of this conditional distribution
of Y given X
and you can also flip the order
right so let's think a little bit about
what it means
so that means that the entropy of so the
mutual information will be high
if the if this term is high if the first
term is high so that means that the
entropy of the of the of the
Distribution on its own is high so we
don't know what x is going to be
and this term needs to be low so but we
don't know what x is going to be it's a
kind of almost a uniform distribution
let's say but if I told you something
about y
you would know exactly what x would be
all right so it's kind of X on its own
it's very very random but as soon as you
know about why X isn't random at all you
know exactly what x is and that would
mean that there's High Mutual
information between the two
right so let's go through a little
exercise so I'll give you two random
events and I'll ask whether these
correspond to high Mutual inference
there's High Mutual information between
them or low Mutual information that you
know
right so is there a high Mutual
information between X and Y where X says
that it's going to rain tomorrow
or it rains tomorrow and why says
streets are wet tomorrow
there's a high Mutual information
yeah it's high neutral information right
if you knew that streets are wet
tomorrow you would know that it rains
tomorrow if you knew that it rains
tomorrow then you would know that it
that the streets will be wet tomorrow
but on its own you can't really tell if
it's going to rain tomorrow or if the
streets are going to be are going to be
wet tomorrow
all right another example let's say
access it rains tomorrow and Y says we
find Life on Mars tomorrow High initial
information
no
two events are fairly there's a lot of
uncertainty in both of them
right and even though if I told you that
it rains tomorrow that wouldn't really
reveal much information about whether
we'll find Life on Mars tomorrow
all right
so there's one example of mutual
information that is actually very useful
in robotics
and this is called empowerment and it
was introduced by pulani at all
and the form of that Mutual information
looks like this as the dimensional
information between the next state and
the action
so basically the entropy of the next
State minus the conditional entropy of
the next state given the action
right so why do you think it's called
empowerment any any ideas
yes
yeah it measures how much the robot can
influence the next state given its own
actions that's right so it basically
tells you how empowered of an individual
someone is right like if your actions
can really influence the next day that
we're all going to see right if you're
the president of the United States then
your actions are really powerful they
will they will change what we're gonna
see next
right and the same with robots so if we
want robots if we want to optimize for
empowerment that means that we want
robots to take actions that have high
influence on the next state they're
going to see so they'll really influence
the environment
all right cool so we discussed a few
information theoretic Concepts and uh
now we'll use some of them to talk about
skill Discovery algorithms
right so first I'll talk about one
algorithm that isn't really a skill
Discovery algorithm that kind of gets us
in the in the right mindset and this is
the algorithm called Soft Q learning
so so far when we talked about Q
learning we talked about always taking
the arc Max of the Q function right so
we had some kind of Q function that is
plotted here
and then our policy would be always
trying to take the max of that Q
function and this would be so it would
be a very peaky gaussian that only cares
about this this very uh the peak of the
Q function
but what that means sometimes is
throughout training we'll want our
policy to to commit always to the
current key function right it will
always try to find the peak of the Q
function and then go with that
so sometimes it actually can have some
catastrophic influence on how the agent
develops because it can commit to a
solution to the sub-optimal just
initially the Q function isn't well
fitted yet it doesn't represent the
environment very well and it will commit
to it fully
so instead what we might want to do is
maybe have a policy that doesn't put all
of its probability Mass on the max of
the Q function but it also puts a little
bit of probability Mass on another Peak
that's a little bit lower
right this way we are we don't fully
commit to a solution straight away
well kind of like you know hedge our
bets a little bit
all right there's actually another
motivation for this which comes from
neuroscience and inverse optimal control
which talks about the following if we
had a if we had a dog and we were asking
the duck to come to us
if we only cared about if we wanted to
describe the behavior of the dog and we
were only talking about this Arc Max of
the Q function then the only trajectory
that would make sense within that
framework would be the straight
trajectory that goes straight to us the
optimal trajectory that's the only
trajectory that we can describe using
that using that framework right we
always think that the dog is optimizing
for the reward the reward is you know
you get a little snack when you come to
me so the only behavior that makes sense
for the doc within this framework is you
know run towards me and don't deviate at
all
but we know that in reality you know
maybe there will be something
interesting in a way maybe the duck will
wander around a little bit and the
trajectory won't be just straight and we
want to be able to describe all of those
trajectories as well
so to do this in either stochastic
optimal control people introduce this
additional people basically started
talking about a little bit of
stochasticity in the policy as well
so it's a stochastic optimal policy it
doesn't mean that the dog always runs
directly towards you but it can also
deviate a little bit and it's still an
optimal policy it's just stochastic
all right so it turns out that the
reward function for a q function like
this
is uh includes a term that we just
discussed
so instead of just optimizing for the
reward as we as we have done so far or
we are maximizing this whole objective
over number of time steps
we are also going to add an additional
entropy term
entropy of our recurrent policy
all right so what that means is that not
only I want you to optimize for the
rewards but I also want you to have a
little bit of entropy I don't want you
to commit too early
all right so I don't want you to be like
very picky I want you to I want the
distribution to be a little bit broader
that will result in in higher entropy
so it turns out that if you if you do
that and carry out the the math this is
our Q learning algorithm that we had
before
it will look very different it will do
very similar except a few differences
instead of taking the max over the queue
you'll be taking a soft Max here and the
policy won't be just the arguments of
the Q function but it will be actually
proportional to the exponent of the
advantage
all right but the the more important
part is that when you do this you will
it will result in policies that look
like this so there are a little bit more
random policies right we are still far
from discovering skills but now we have
policies that can do a little bit more
so let's see what what that actually
results in so this is a paper by Thomas
harnoya at all uh called Deep
energy-based policies
so first thing we can notice is that
exploration Works a little bit
differently in these policies so here on
the left you can see an a final policy
that is obtained by this ant trying to
get to this goal without using soft cue
learning so if using standard standard Q
learning so you can see that the ant
just decided to the reward is the
distance to that goal so the end just
decided probably early in its training
to commit to that path and then it's
really hard to kind of uncommit to just
say well maybe I should explore this
other path this is very sub-optimal
Behavior given that you know here you're
getting more and more and more rewards
but then you realize that it doesn't
really get you fully to the goal
however with soft Q learning it's not as
committed so it doesn't just like pick a
solution at the very beginning it
actually keeps its option options open
and then that allows it to explore a
little bit further and then eventually
discover the right solution
all right let's look at one other aspect
of it
so here we are pre-training our and and
the reward is just the speed so you can
move in any direction you will just get
a reward if you're fast
so here on the left you will see the the
resulting policy
without this additional entropy term and
on the right you will see the Sub-Q
learning policy
so you can see that in this case all of
the and so all of the different random
seeds basically are moving towards the
same direction versus let's
play this again maybe
versus in this case the ant is kind of
exploring and you know going in all
kinds of different directions because it
doesn't want to commit to a single
solution
what that means is that if we were to
take this policy on the right that that
explores the state space a little bit
better it will be probably more
fine-tunable right like if you wanted to
just then go to a particular corner of
the workspace like right here then this
policy already visited the corner maybe
it already knows how to get there and we
can find into this versus with this
policy it would potentially need to
unlearn something and learn how to get
there again
and then one other aspect that you get
when adding this this additional entropy
term is the robustness
so here is a robot trying to stack these
two Lego blocks
and you can see that you can this is the
soft Q learning policy and you can see
that you can perturb the robot quite a
bit and it still figures out a way to
get there
so it explored quite a lot of its of its
state space because it had this
additional entropy term that kind of uh
you know allowed it to to explore a
little bit more and now it knows how to
recover from all of these different
states
right if you try just standard Q
learning it's quite likely that it will
just go straight from the initial
position straight down minimize that
that uh that distance but then it
wouldn't be very robust to any
perturbations
all right
so this is yeah there's a question
sorry
so in the first hand exploration I'm
Amazed
I'll bring them up
yeah so the question is how would you
solve this ant mace problem
um in something like dtpg when you don't
have additional entropy term
yeah so usually to encourage some kind
of exploration you will add some kind of
noise and then you would hope that you
would find the right path
but then it will probably be very
dependent on the random seed that you
use so sometimes it will do it sometimes
it won't it will come into the wrong
solution at the beginning and there is
no really good way to recover
but if you look at like at an algorithm
like a soft actor critic which is kind
of another version of ddpg that includes
the entropy term then it should be able
to discover the right solution all the
time
oh yeah that's a that's a good question
so does that mean that if you optimize
for additionally for the entropy does
that mean that the variance between
different runs will be smaller usually
it's the case yeah so with ddpg you're a
little bit more reliant on the right
random seed that just happened to
explore that certain that part of the
state space with Sac you're always
exploring all kinds of part all the
parts so you should be able to find the
solution better or more reliably
okay
cool
all right so so we want to learn diverse
skills so far we only talked about how
we can just learn a skill that's a
little bit more stochastic
so when we learn diverse skills what we
want is some kind of way to control this
stochasticity so we want to be able to
for the ant not just to go in all the
directions but also to say well I want
you to go up or I want you to go left or
I want you to go right and so on
so we'll condition our policy on on this
additional variable that we'll use to
control what kind of skill we want to we
want to ask for
so let's call it just a task index or a
skill index Z
and let's say that this is our ant or
just some kind of robot and we want it
on its own to explore this environment
so to go in all the different directions
but we want it to be controllable right
so we wanted such that if I set Z to a
particular parameter it will go in One
Direction if I set it to some other
parameter it will go in another
Direction and so on
so for instance if I set Z equals zero
it will go up here and it will result in
the screen trajectory if I set Z equal
one it will result in this trajectory C2
in this one and so on and it will be all
different in that case I'm kind of
starting to discover the skills and now
they're controllable
it's not just a stochastic policy
so
um soft Q learning is also referred to
as maxed entropy reinforcement learning
or maxed and reinforcement learning
because we add this additional entropy
term that we are maximizing
so why can't we just use max maxed
entropy reinforcement learning instead
so first action entropy is not the same
as state entropy so in the previous case
we wanted to make sure that the agent
doesn't commit to a single action right
that kind of keeps its distribution of
our actions broad but that doesn't
necessarily mean that it will end up
that it will end up in many different
states it sometimes happens like we saw
in the end but it doesn't need to happen
right so agent can take very different
actions but lend in very similar States
in addition to this these marks and
policies are stochastics but they're not
always controllable this is what we what
we just discussed right so the ant can
go in all the different directions but
we can't really say well I want you to
go in that particular one
so intuitively what we want is we want
low diversity for a fixed Z so if I told
you what what skill I want I want you to
know what to do
but High diversity across these right so
if I didn't tell you what to do then I
want if I were to like marginalize over
Z and just look at all of these
trajectories I want them to cover the
state space well
right
that has some resemblance to one of the
terms that we were discussing where one
of the term was talking about light
diversity if you knew the Z and the
other term was talking about if you
don't know Z or if you don't know this
or this other random variable
um there should be high entropy so keep
that in mind
but let's see how we can design some
kind of reward function that will get us
there
so the intuition is that different
skills should visit with a different
state-space regions right so for
different skills we want to explore
different parts of the state space
all right so we'll try to think of a
reward function that is not task
dependent right so we don't really want
to say I want you to go up or I want you
to go to the side it should be task
agnostic
and it should just promotes diversity it
should just promote going in all the
different directions and be controllable
at the same time
so that reward function should probably
be dependent on the skill variable Z
right because for different skills it
might look a little bit different so
let's just say that it's going to be
dependent on that and then we'll sum
over all disease to get the reward for
the entire policy
and what we would want is we want to
reward the states that are unlikely for
any other disease right so for a
particular skill I want you to go to
states that none of the other skills
would have gone to
right that would mean that this skills
is as really specific it's different
than all the other skills and if all the
skills were were to do that then we'll
get every skill that is very original
and altogether that will span this
diversity of behaviors
all right so here's one idea
let's train a classifier
this P of Z given s
that tells us given the state what skill
it came from
right we'll just do this using
supervised learning we can roll out the
trajectory we know what Z we we set when
we rolled it out we had our policy that
was conditioned on Z
and then we'll take this trajectory
every state from this trajectory and
we'll try to fit a classifier that tells
us what Z did that state come from
and then in addition to learning that
classifier we'll also set that the
reward function for the agent would be
to maximize the log probability of Z
given s
right what what does that mean so both
the classif the classifier and the
reward function and the agent is trying
to maximize this log likelihood
right so what what does that mean so the
the agent itself is rewarded by helping
the classifier
right so
um let's think about it this way we have
a policy that produces some actions in
the environment and then we get the
states policies conditioned on the skill
and then in addition to this we have
this classifier and the discriminator
that takes a state and tells us what
skill it came from and this is the same
kind of skill that we input to the
policy
right so but why why does it work why
why it doesn't make sense
so let's go through a little example of
how exactly this will work
so let's say we have two different
trajectories that were produced by two
different Z's so we are at the very
beginning of our training the agent
doesn't really know that the frenzy
should lead to different trajectories so
both of them are fairly similar
right so we produce this is this is
let's say produce the green one is
produced for Z equals zero the blue one
is produced for Z equal one
now we are trying to fit the classifier
to it so let's say that the decision
boundary that the classifier learns it
stress to classify these two
trajectories it tries to tell you given
the state is it Z 0 or Z equal one and
this is the decision boundary it found
so it's not great but you know it's
doing its best
so now the agent is trying to optimize
for the same loss as the classifier so
the agent now is trying to produce new
trajectories that will help the class of
the current classifier the current
decision rendering
so the next two trajectories that the
agent will produce for Z equals zero and
Z equal one
will be a little bit further apart so
that this lock likelihood is a little
bit better
right so it produces two trajectories
that are easy to easily distinguishable
and then the classifier optimizes its
decision boundary again
so given these two trajectories it makes
a small correction and now it's a little
bit better now the agent does it again
so given the new decision boundary the
agent produces two trajectories that
help the classifier
and then we adjust the decision boundary
and so on
so we kind of played this game but they
play it they they're on the same team
right the agent is trying to produce
trajectories that are easy to classify
and the classifier is then classifying
learning how to classify these
trajectory
right are there any questions to this
yes
so this classifier here what does it
take as input this is just a single
stator or a trajectory so in this
particular paper called diversity is all
you need by Ben eisenbach at all
um this is just on single state
so it looks at every single state but
you could condition it on on something
else on the whole trajectory or
something like that
now I guess one question to all of you
would be what would happen if we
condition it not on just every single
state but let's say only on the last
state of the trajectory
um
that's right they could look exactly the
same way all the way except at the very
end where they would need to diverge
because that's what we will be
classifying but yeah that's correct so
you can decide kind of what kind of
diversity you want by deciding what
you're conditioning this classifier on
if you're conditioning it on every
single state that means every single
state has to be different for both of
these skills and there's actually
different choices that you can take here
you can condition only on the last date
on the first date and last day on all of
the states on all kinds of different
things and there's different works that
actually discuss this this choice
function
[Music]
yes that's a that's a great intuition
and we'll get to it in I think one slide
or two slides yes that's that's exactly
correct
all right so first a few examples of
what kind of tasks they could learn what
kind of skills they could learn so again
they just dropped an agent in an
environment and then they have this very
generic reward function that is not
environment specific right it just
rewards diversity and helps this
classifier
and then they can try different Z's
after this process and just see what
they correspond to so in this half
cheetah environment it turns out that
one of the Z's corresponds to the
cheetah running running forward the
other one corresponds to cheetah doing
these backflips or front flips
the other one corresponds to cheetah
running backwards so it can suddenly do
all kinds of different things
here's another example of an ant so you
can see that sometimes and just does
like some random things jumps in place
that's kind of all kinds of different
things sometimes it runs in one
particular direction
and they also traded in the simple
environment the mountain car and you can
see that some of the Z's some of the
skills that they learned actually
correspond to solving the task so
sometimes you can kind of by accident
stumble upon a skill that solves a task
that the original outro of the
environment had in mind but it just you
know emerged from this diversity
objective
all right so
going back to your to your question yes
that's correct yeah so just to repeat
the the
question or the note is that
um this corresponds to unsupervised
reinforcement learning because this is
not really specific to a task right we
designed a reward function that is Task
agnostic it doesn't know that you know
the goal of mountain car is to get to
the top yes that's exactly right it's
completely unsupervised in this case
right cool so now a connection to Mutual
information that we talked about just a
second ago so so far we talked about the
reward function optimizing this log
probability
so remember that Mutual information is
equal to this entropy minus the relative
entropy so let's think of the mutual
information between our Z variable the
skill
and the state
right
so that Mutual information is equal to
the entropy of Z
minus the conditional entropy of Z given
s
right
so now this first part
we don't really have that much control
over this we can just say that every Z
is equally likely right so we have a
uniform prior that will lead us that
will lead to the to the highest entropy
what that means is basically every skill
has a chance to go right like you can
sample disease uniformly and you don't
just focus on one particular Z so that's
easy to do
and then the second part
is the entropy of Z given s and this is
exactly minimized by maximizing log of P
of Z given s right so this tells you
that if I if I know what s it is then I
should if I told you what s you visited
you should be able to very clearly tell
me what Z came from
so this is exactly the note that you
made earlier
and then
um so this is the paper called diversity
is all you need and then there's a paper
actually that came before this paper
that discusses a different choice of
conditioning
um and there's actually a few more
called this one's called variational
intrinsic control and I also encourage
you to take a look at that
all right so we talk a little bit about
how we can discover skills
um let's talk about how we can actually
use those skills
oh are we on time okay
so
let's talk about this diversity is all
you need paper so we have this policy
now that is conditioned on Z and for
different diseases can do a bunch of
different things
so let's say we want to now use those
skills to accomplish some kind of tasks
that we care about in the world so let's
say we want to have an ant navigate from
this point to that point to this point
and so on
so how can we use the Learned skills to
accomplish a task any ideas
yes
you can just sample from your skills
condition on what your objective is okay
yeah so you can try different skills and
kind of find which ones will work yep
any other ideas
right yeah can we just [ __ ] you on the
New Castle can we just fine tune so how
would you exactly fine-tune
okay Trey yeah so you could do it the
way that you're describing so you can
basically form it as an additional
reinforcement learning problem where now
you'll learn a policy that operates on
Z's rather than on actions right so
you'll just learn another policy of the
action space of that policy is I can
comment that skill this skill that skill
and so on and maybe you act for a
certain number of steps and then after
this you get to choose the next skill
all right so this is actually what they
show in diversities while you need paper
and they can get cheetah to run over
these hurdles they can also do a little
ant navigation and they show some
results for it where it actually works
um but one question is can we do better
and it turns out that we actually that
we actually can
so
what's the problem of this so the
problem with the solution that we
discussed just now is that we'll be
discovering all kinds of different
skills and some of those skills might
not be particularly useful so sometimes
we might just have these skills that
correspond to the end just kind of like
staying in place or jumping a little bit
or motor bubbling doing different things
because as long as the skill is
different it will be considered a
separate skill
so we maybe want to change the objective
a little bit so that we can produce
skills that are a little bit more useful
and then the second problem we have is
that it's not actually very easy to use
the learning skill so right now the
solution that we came up with is that we
would learn another policy on top of
those skills which means we need to do
another reinforcement learning problem
and reinforcement learning is hard and
now you have to explore in the Z space
which would make it a little bit better
but it's still you know quite a lot of
work that you have to do
all right so we'll think about one
question which will actually contribute
to both of these problems and the
question is what makes a useful skill
what makes the skill useful
all right so I'll give you
two examples
of a skill that is not particularly
useful
right so we can have this and that turns
upside down and it's kind of like it's
kind of tricky to to see what's what's
going on and then here's another skill
where there's this baby playing with
Jenga and it pulls the wrong thing and
you know results in a catastrophe
and here's another set of skills that
seem a little bit more useful so here's
an ant running forward
and here's this cartoon character
juggling
so there could be a lot of opinions what
what makes skill useful
but there's one approach
um that was published recently and that
tries to address this question and says
the following
consequences are hard for to predict for
skills that are not very useful
and consequences are easy to predict if
the skill is useful so if you're doing
something useful that means it will be
relatively easy to predict what's going
to happen next
right that might be a little bit
controversial but let's run with it and
let's see what we get
all right
so this is introducing this paper called
that by um Archer charm Idol
and it talks about a different kind of
mutual information
so it will try to change the mutual
information such that we can incorporate
this product predictability objective
right so we want our skills that are not
only novel but that are also predictable
right and we'll think that the
assumption is that predictable skills
means more useful skills
right so this is the mutual information
we had before between Z and S
so now we'll have the slightly different
Mutual information that we'll try to
maximize which is the initial
information between S Prime comma Z
given s
right we haven't really talked about
this conditional Mutual information so
let's talk about it real quick
so this is the definition of the mutual
information we had before
so if we make it a conditional
we can just condition everything on this
additional conditional variable so this
spiritual information would be X comma R
comma y given Z
and then this would be a joint
distribution condition on Z
and the marginalized condition on Z as
well
so we can now rewrite this objective
given the definition
as following it would be the max of
these two conditional entropies so one
entropy says that it should be a high
entropy of the next state given the
current state and the other one says
should be low entropy of the next state
given the current state and the Z
so what that means is that future so S
Prime what what we're going to see next
is hard to predict for for different
skills if I don't know what Z is right
so it's difficult to say what's going to
happen next
and the second one says the future
should be really predictable for a given
skill so if I told you what Z is then
you should be very easily able to tell
me what S Prime is going to happen next
and if we optimize this objective that
means we'll end up with skills that are
predictable right so for every Z this
should be very low so we should be able
to tell what's going to happen next
so you can approximate it so that you
can actually optimize it and it results
in something like this and the two
important terms are the numerator and
the denominator the numerator and the
numerator here corresponds to
um
having this this additional neural
network that we are training which tells
you what as Prime you're going end up in
given the current s and the Z the skill
that you commanded
and we're trying to to maximize this
whole thing so that means we are trying
to make this look likelihood as high as
possible so we want to be able to tell
which state we're going to end up in
and does the numerator then says for
every other skill the future should be
hard to predict
so if we sum over all disease it should
be hard
they're marginalizing over Z here
all right cool
so
what that means is now we have a neural
network we have to fit to to
maximize the subjective
which is this neural network that tells
us what next state we're going to see
given the current state and the skill
this is fairly similar to something that
you already learned about in model-based
reinforced learning which is the
transition model of the environment
right what's the next state we're going
to see given the current state and the
action
so we are learning kind of like a
Dynamics model but it's a skill Dynamics
motor model compared to a conventional
Global Dynamics model that just tells us
what's the next state we're going to see
given an action this one tells us what's
the next state we're going to see given
a scale
all right and then skills will be
optimized so that this skill Dynamics
will be easier to model right so that
skills will try to produce such as
primes so that this this is easy
all right so it's easy to fit that model
right and hopefully that should result
in a little bit more predictable skills
right so let's look at the algorithm so
we would initialize our policy and our
uh the skill Dynamics model Q
then we will sample a skill from a prior
this would be a uniform prior for every
episode
in this case it's really as a gaussian
but let's just imagine it's uniform we
sample different skills
and then we would collect new on policy
samples given those these right so we'll
have for does Z will collect this
trajectory for the Z dot trajectory and
so on
then given that we can compute the
reward for all of those transitions
and we can update our Dynamics model so
our reward is now dependent on the skill
Dynamics model and we can compute the
reward based on this and we can also
update the Dynamics model itself
so we do that
and then we can update the policy using
any reinforcement learning algorithm in
this particular case I believe we used
sac
right so kind of relatively you know
comparable to diversity is all you need
now it's just a little a slightly
different model that we are fitting
before we are fitting this model that
tells you
given the state what skill you're going
end up in here we are fitting this model
that tells you given my current state
and the skill what next date I'm going
to see
so relatively small change
all right so this is the algorithm
and we do this over and over again
so let's look at some of the results so
first we see that the things that we
learn if we just look across all the
different Z's that we can set
seem a little bit more useful right so
the ant actually they result to and
adding in all kinds of different
directions and there is less of these
fewer of these skills where the ant is
just like doing random things
we also see that if we were to plot the
trajectories of that the ant takes
in in diversity is all you need in Diane
algorithm they will look like this
versus in that they're much more
um
they're much much easier to predict
right they're a little bit simpler if
the and decide to go see in a certain
direction it continues going in this
direction because that means that the
the skill Dynamics model is easy to
predict right it doesn't change its mind
all the time
right so that seems kind of useful
that also means that our humanoid when
we train it on the humanoid ends up
walking in different directions as well
all right so now we have skills that are
maybe a little bit more that are more
predictable and maybe they're a little
bit more useful but we also had this
other problem in Diana algorithm where
we didn't really know how to use those
skills so we had to learn another policy
on top of it
so now because we have the skilled
Dynamics model
we can actually use that model for
model-based planning the same way as you
did in the model based reinforcement
learning lecture
right
so we can do the following we can
we can consider different Z's and for
every Z we can predict what kind of
States we are going to see right as we
did in model based reinforcement
learning then a computer estimate the
cumulative reward for all of them for a
particular task and then update the
planner
so now we can use a planning procedure
to tell us which skill to actually use
right because for every skill we can
kind of unfold it see what kind of
future we're going to see with that
skill using our skill Dynamics model and
then we can see how that corresponds to
the reward that we actually care about
and we don't need to do reinforcement
learning here we can do the planning
right so in this case we'll be planning
for skills not actions that's the
difference to model based rail but
otherwise it's exactly the same
and in this case we also don't need any
additional rollouts we can just think of
a task that we want to learn that we
want to adjust our skills to and do it
in zero shot because we can just imagine
what the Futures will be for different
skills and then put them together
and that actually results in
um in this task where we can have the
ant go to the different goal locations
and we can do this without any
additional rollouts right so we can just
optimize offline using the planning
algorithm to decide which skills we
should be we should be using at any
given point and then we can find the
right skills offline and then just
execute those skills and the end is able
to navigate to all these different
points
we can also do the same with the
humanoid where we can optimize for which
skills to use offline and then use those
online to to tell the human eye where to
go which skill to use so we don't need
to do reinforcement learning at this
point we can do it all offline
right so a quick summary we talked about
two skill Discovery algorithms that both
use Mutual information just slightly
different Mutual informations and we saw
how the choice I've been showing
information actually influences the
algorithm
in particular in that we use
predictability of a skill as a as a
proxy for a skill being useful
and then that's designed this method
that optimizes for both predictability
and diversity
and then we showed that we can use
model-based planning in the skill space
after that
and then as one of you already mentioned
this opens up new avenues such as
unsupervised meta reinforcement learning
or unsupervised multitasker enforcement
learning and so on where we can just and
this is actually describing this paper
here by abhisha Gupta at all showing how
you can just have an unsupervised reward
function like you have in the case of
Diane or dats and have the agent just
explore unsupervisely and then do meta
learning in those tasks so now you can
do unsupervised reinforcement learning
where the agent is coming up with its
own tasks
all right cool
are there any questions at this point
all right great
attendance left let's talk about
hierarchical reinforcement learning
so we know the motivations we can
perform tasks at various levels of
abstraction it might potentially also
help with exploration
so it's actually quite tricky to talk
about hierarchical reinforcement there's
a lot of algorithms out there so I
thought that instead of presenting just
one or two of them I'll just tell you
about the the design choices that you
can make when thinking about
hierarchical reinforcement learning
algorithms and then we'll go through
some examples and we'll pick what
choices the the outdoors made so I'll be
asking you to tell me what choices the
address made here
all right so if we were to design just a
hierarchical reinforcement learning
algorithm it might look like something
like this we have an environment
environment produces an action and then
we have a policy this has this
superscript L which means this is a low
level policy so it takes the state from
the environment and then acts on that
environment
and then it takes the next state from
that and it acts on that and so on just
like in normal reinforcement learning
but now in addition to this we'll also
have a high level policy Pi h
and the high-level policy will take the
initial state
and then it will command what what kind
of skill should the low level policy be
doing
right and can command it for a certain
number of time steps or it can command
it up until the level policy says it's
done but it basically
plans or produces actions that are a
little bit on a higher level of
abstraction
and then we'll we'll say that this
policy only gets to act for three time
steps so then after this we'll get the
next state and then this high level
policy given that state will need to say
well what should the low-level policy be
doing now
all right so there are four different
design choices that I want to show you
there are four different axes
so first the one decision that people
often make is whether the low level
policy is goal condition or not goal
condition
all right so you can have this low-level
policy be conditioned on particular
goals so then so like a state that you
want to get to so then the high level
policy needs to produce a state here
so a particular state that you need to
get to and then the low level policy
just can do
um gold condition reinforcement learning
but it doesn't have to command States it
can be some abstract Z like we had in
the case of Diane for instance that uh
we don't really know exactly what it
means but it commands it to the policy
and then policy needs to act accordingly
so that's one decision
the other decision is whether we want to
have a pre-trained policy in the lobe
level or whether we want to train both
of these policies end to end
right so in the case of Diane and in
diversity all you need is we would first
pre-train the low-level policy to do all
kinds of different things given the Z
and then we'll in addition to this
afterwards train a high level policy
that just commands disease right so we
had the pre-trained low level policy and
the high level policy was trained
afterwards we can also do it all end to
end
all right then the the next choice is we
can have the low-level policy
self-terminate
um or act for a certain number of time
steps
right so in this case it's acting for
three time steps and that's it so this
is the budget that it has but it could
be also that the low-level policy has an
action that says well terminate now and
if it terminates that's when the high
level action high level policy gets to
act again
all right
and then we have the the choice that we
usually have which is are they learning
on policy or off policy that depends on
the real algorithm we use
all right so let's run for this exercise
I'll be asking you uh I'll be giving
describing a work some some work on
hierarchical reinforcement learning
briefly and then I'll ask you what kind
of choices the actors made so let me do
the first one to kind of explain how
this works so let's consider the Diane
approach
so in this case the level of policy is
not a goal condition right that's
conditioned on the subtract variable Z
the low level is pre-trained it's not
trained end to end
we didn't discuss this but actually in
in Diane they were running the low-level
policy at the fixed rate for a fixed
number of time steps it wasn't
self-terminating
and it was all trained on policy as well
all right
all right so let's go through a few of
these examples and I'll be asking you
what what design choices that the
address make
so this is a work called learning
locomotor controllers by Nicholas
hassadol
and it works as following so this is the
little this is a little screenshot from
the paper
we have a high level controller or a
high level policy that is a recurrent
controller
and then we have a low level controller
right here
now this command for the for the low
level controller is updated every case
steps so it asks it to act for K steps
and then it asks it again
it also uses proper set of information
and there's additional task specific
information that is fed only to the high
level controller but not to the low
level controller so the high level
controller has some privileged
information
right in addition both the high level
controller and the low level controllers
are trained separately so they first
train the low level thing and then the
high level thing on top of that
they're both trained with policy
gradients
and they add hierarchical noise to this
controller for exploration purposes
so then they can show something like
this where they have the snake robot and
they can show that by just inputting the
noise to the high level controller it
actually results in some sensible
Behavior so you can have some
exploration benefits from this hierarchy
all right and then they show some
results showing that that actually works
fairly well
so the question to you is
um is it a goal condition or not goal
condition the low-level policy
let me just say one goal condition who
thinks it's goal condition raise your
hand
okay just a few people who thinks it's
not a good condition
many more people okay yeah it's not a
good condition we didn't explicitly
talked about it but it just sends a z
command to the level into the local
policy all right is it pre-trained or
end-to-end trained is it pre-trained who
thinks it's pre-trained
right quite a few who thinks it's end to
end
nobody yep it's pre-trained
that's a little too far away yeah it's
fixed rate
um is it on policy or off policy who
thinks it's on policy
more or less everybody who thinks it's
our policy
nobody yeah it's trained using policy
gradient so it's on policy right cool
another work option credit architecture
work by bacon at all
so first an option is described as
following
um it's actually used fairly often in
hierarchical rainforced learning it's
written by this as denoted by this Omega
is it triple in which this I Omega is
the initiation set so that's when the
option can be activated
then it also has this policy Pi Omega
which is a policy an intraoption policy
so this is the policy the low level
policy that actually gets to act on that
low level state and then we have this
beta Omega which is a termination
function so this is when the option
knows when it can terminate
all right so here's a little plot from
this paper showing a standard mdp where
we just acted every time step and with
options we the low level option gets to
act at every time step but the option
itself can jump between them sounds like
a high level policy
and they also this is a screenshot from
the paper where they have an environment
that gives you States and then they have
a policy over option here other options
that decides which kind of option which
kind of policy the low level option
policy gets to go so it decides whether
it's this policy this policy or that
policy
all right a few a few more facts so
option is a self-terminating meaning
policy so the option itself can decide
when to terminate
everything here was trained together
both the high level policy over options
as well as the options themselves with
policy gradients
and here's some visualizations showing
that the actual termination conditions
that it learned in this uh in this four
room grid World actually correspond very
often to the exit States
kind of interesting and then they show
some additional results
all right so let's go over to the design
choices who thinks it's gold conditioned
who thinks it's not gold condition
pretty much everybody great who thinks
it's pre-trained
who thinks it's end to end
everyone great it's a little too easy
who thinks it's self-terminating
pretty much everyone yep that's correct
who thinks it's on policy
yeah pretty much everyone as well great
cool all right this one was an easy one
all right another one relay policy
learning work by Abhishek Gupta at all
so it works as following we have a
low-level policy and a high level policy
the high level policy is sending goals
to actual State goals to the low-level
policy then then gets to act for a
certain number of time steps right then
it does goal condition learning for the
low-level policy as well as gold
condition learning for the high level
policy using hindsight relabeling
actually
all right
so the way this is trained as first we
collect demonstrations kind of in the
environment doing all kinds of different
things
um so for instance in this kitchen
environment it can be robot going to all
kinds of different locations
and then we do data relabeling where we
can take a long trajectory and relabel
the high level as well as the low level
goals for both the high level policy and
the low level policy
then we start with the imitation
learning and then we continue with
policy gradients to Define tuning using
a reward function for both flow level
and the high level policy
all right so a few more facts as goal
condition policies with relabeling we
use demonstrations to pre-train
everything
and oh well it's done on positive policy
gradients
and here are some results so here is a
long Horizon goal that we're trying to
achieve and you can see that relay
policy learning is able to to do this
fairly well so it opens the microwave
moves the kettle opens the cabinet and
so on and some other equivalents are not
able to do that
all right so is it a goal condition or
not is it who thinks it's called
condition
yep it's called condition who thinks
it's pre-trained
so the people who thinks it's end-to-end
train
one person yeah so it's actually trained
end to end it's pre-trained in terms of
both policies are pre-trained with
demonstrations but they're still learned
together at all times
is it self-terminating who thinks it's
self-terminating
nobody who thinks it's fixed rate
yep
it's uh who thinks it's on policy
yeah pretty much everyone
all right cool we have one more
algorithm but I think we're running out
of time so I'll skip this one
and a quick summary so we have multiple
design choices and Frameworks for
hierarchical rainforce warning
it usually helps with exploration and
with temporarily extended tasks with
these long horizontastic what you've
seen in the kitchen environment
but it can be quite difficult to get it
to work so you're adding an additional
an additional policy you have to
optimize for both of the policies
sometimes the low-level policy is kind
of changing underneath your feet under
your feet so you have to accommodate for
this if you use an off policy algorithm
and so on so it's actually quite tricky
to get to work
and it also seems like a natural
extension for harder RL problems where
we have to do longer Horizon tasks but
often it's quite tricky to get to work
and there's actually some interesting
work talking about why hierarchy
sometimes works and they do a decent
analysis showing in what cases it helps
and where it doesn't
all right so we talked about these four
different things thank you very much for
your attention and just to remind you on
Monday we have the homework for you on
Wednesday project Milestone is due and
next week please attend the two guest
lectures that are going to be really
interesting I think thank you